la rencontre avec le président Macron a
duré trois heures hier soir volodi
mirzelinski repart avec la promesse de
livraison d'armes il n'y a pas de liste
officielle la France va livrer des
avions à l'Ukraine non j'ai pas parlé
d'avion j'ai parlé de missile et j'ai
parlé de formation Macron qui dans le
même temps vente l'attractivité de la
France auprès de grands patrons
étrangers dont Elon Musk regardait le
propriétaire de Twitter Tesla ou encore
SpaceX a été reçu ce matin à l'Élysée
sixième édition de tous France l'Élysée
et bien communique des chiffres records
13 milliards d'euros d'investissement
pour cette année avec à la clé 8000
emplois directs créés et surtout la
preuve que la stratégie industrielle que
nous avons mise en place avec le
président de la République avec méthode
avec détermination et avec constance
depuis 2017 sans jamais varier donne des
résultats spectaculaires
pour la quatrième année consécutive la
France est le pays le plus attractif
d'Europe pour la quatrième année
consécutive c'est le fruit de norréforme
de notre travail d'un engagement des
talents de la France
la course à la recherche des prix bas un
défi pour de plus en plus de français
dans les rayons de ce supermarché entre
les promotions réductions et le panier
anti-inflation difficile de s'y
retrouver à la place du consommateur
c'est incompréhensible c'est-à-dire que
l'industriel vous dit je peux rien faire
nous les distributeurs on dit on peut
faire quelque chose c'est un peu
toujours le sujet du poker menteur j'ai
dit à Bruno Le Maire que j'ai rencontré
s'il y a des grandes marques qui abusent
il faut arrêter de se renvoyer la balle
il faut dire qui le fait de manière
précise
que la dénoncer les marionnettes
que lorsque les prix de gros explosent
que les industriels demandent une
renégociation pour répercuter à la
hausse on leur dise oui et tout le monde
les suit et lorsque les prix de gros
baisse et qu'on leur demande de venir
rouvrir des négociations commerciales il
répond non vous l'avez compris aucun
industriel n'a intérêt à venir baisser
ses bénéfices ou ses résultats en
octroyant des baisses au distributeur
donc seul un cadre contraignant du
gouvernement permettra la renégociation
vous avez passé votre hausse vous allez
on va peut-être vous demander de passer
les baisses plus vite donc oui on va
remettre un peu tout le monde autour de
la table pour essayer de baisser
certains prix pour accompagner nos
compatriotes nous ferons la transparence
sur le niveau de marge d'un certain
nombre de multinationales industrielles
on le fera dans les prochains jours les
prix orgueil incapacités c'est comme ça
que vous parlez d'Emmanuel Macron
il a fait preuve d'orgueil voire
d'incapacité il y a un point
d'interrogation
penser que c'est bon pour ma pomme de de
faire ce qu'on fait sur les retraites de
porter des textes difficiles de subir et
d'accepter la popularité qui va avec
sur cnews dans valeur actuelle on laisse
cette idéologie prospérée en ne
respectant pas les règles
vous mettez en cause des médias cnews
eux on sait qu'elle est leur stratégie
on sait qu'elle est la stratégie de
Bolloré je mets entre eux comme beaucoup
de personnes malentenées madame
Tondelier parle de ces news sans jamais
regarder la chaîne écouter nos émissions
à moi à moins qu'elle les ruquent la
nathem pour défigurer notre chaîne comme
toute la journée vous avez que des
débats entre des gens d'extrême droite
et de droite extrême sans aucune
pluralité sur aucun plateau et aucun
éditorialiste toute la journée sur des
chaînes ou personne ne leur dit rien
vous êtes la bienvenue sur notre plateau
mais j'ai l'impression que vous préférez
le monologue l'intolérance et
l'ex-communication n'hésitez pas madame
je vous le redis vous êtes la bienvenue
premier procès pour Tariq Ramadan il
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à Genève
l'islamologue et jugé pour viol et
contraintes sexuelle sur une femme qui
l'accuse de rapport ultra violents Tariq
Ramadan dit vouloir se battre contre le
mensonge et la manipulation il appelle à
la barre Dieudonné comme témoin ces
images splendides ont été filmées à
l'aide d'une caméra qui utilise un
moteur pour rester sur un axe précis
l'appareil c'est tout simplement fixé
sur un point de la Voie lactée et
s'adapte au mouvement de notre planète
pour nous offrir ce spectacle à couper
le souffle